non qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire voilà elle veut bien se présenter
contre tours est allé sur elle et pour
elle elle est tellement sûr de gagner
nadal à roland garros elle dit venez me
voir c'est comme moi au paddle abonnés
joué contre moi vous moins bon ben voilà
la marine le pen du pas d'album et ou
non merci on babolat jamais rien à
recevoir vos dents balances ton phone
arrive à peine à way ah oui je vous
l'avais invité ou pas je pense qu'on va
l'on va on va essayer de l'habituel
savait qu'elle va venir ça c'est sûr
parce que je pense que et époux on va
voir si elle a le courage de venir mario
vote parce qu'elle va être bousculé
quand même avec toute l'équipe qui a je
vous rappelle l'année prochaine balance
compotes et l'équipe de fou encore voilà
autodata
et c'est vrai que voilà j'aimerai bien
géré à y apprendre pour vraiment la m
voilà devant ses idées voilà et parce
que c'est vrai que je trouve que je ne
sais pas voilà et c'est vrai que quand
marine le pen maintenant elle est assez
rompu à l'exercice vraiment adapté lui
pose des questions
voilà il c'est normal c'est leur métier
qu'elle connaît un petit peu c'est
comment la dent balances ton post est
vrai que c'est un autre exercice et je
pense que on verrait peut-être tout son
vrai visage
l'animal politique voulait l'ennuyer
invités marion maréchal-le pen
ah oui j'ai vu sa vidéo d'ailleurs c'est
bon on va pas vite et non plus s'appelle
balances ton post est pas boulet du post